oh you know for me looking at what we're
not doing I have to come back to to
valuing participation there is a there's
a real sense amongst political media
elites real suspicion amongst political
and media elites that populism is a
scary thing that getting people involved
and engaged as a scary thing because
what are those people now it really is a
dangerous parochialism that that somehow
living in DC gives you a perspective on
the world that most of America doesn't
have it is it's DC is very vulnerable to
groupthink we saw this with the Iraq war
for example I think political and media
elites need to reach out and when they
do they'll find tremendous power power
in the sense of the power to make a
difference not the power to have a big
bigger place to to live or a bigger
salary and that will feel good you know
i think that the primary thing is for
people to be thinking about their but
they're about the future you know that
we tend to get so much drawn into the
rat race and comparing comparing
ourselves to the Joneses and having more
stuff if if everybody just took five
percent or ten percent of their time and
effort and resources and put it against
looking after the future the problems
with the problems would go away
instantly this is an incredibly wealthy
rich society we just need to put a
little bit of that against the problems
you